This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Look, we've all got problems. Sometimes your problem is a massive roadblock in your life. Or maybe it's this little thing that quietly annoys you that you've learned to grudgingly put up with. But regardless of the size of your problem, it would be so great if someone would just fix it for you. And not just fix it. Hyperfix it. On his new podcast, Hyperfixed, host Alex Goldman will get to the bottom of your problem, no matter how big or small.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。听着，我们都有各种烦恼。有时你的烦恼是生活中巨大的绊脚石。或者也许只是一件默默困扰着你、而你已经学会勉强忍受的小事。但无论你的烦恼有多大，如果有人能帮你解决，那真是太棒了。而且不仅是解决。而是彻底搞定。在他的新播客《Hyperfixed》中，主持人亚历克斯·戈德曼将为你刨根问底，找出你烦恼的根源，无论事情大小。
If there is a bottom, results may vary. You may remember Alex as the former co-host of Reply All. When a 99PI listener couldn't play the show on his Mazda car stereo, Alex and his Super Tech Support team helped us track down the issue and create a special Mazda-friendly podcast feed, which we still publish to today. So imagine what he could do for you. Today, we're playing a great story from Alex and his new show. It's very much a design story. He investigates why there's no door in a place where there really should be a door. You'll never shop for sour cream or shredded mozzarella
如果能找到根源的话，结果可能会有所不同。你可能还记得亚历克斯曾是《Reply All》的主播。当一位 99PI 的听众无法在他的马自达汽车音响上播放节目时，亚历克斯和他的“超级技术支持”团队帮我们追踪了问题所在，并制作了一个专门适配马自达的播客订阅源，我们至今仍在发布。所以，想象一下他能为你做些什么。今天，我们将播放一则来自亚历克斯及其新节目的精彩故事。这非常像一个关于设计的故事。他调查了为什么在一个本该有门的地方却没有门。你再也不会
the same way again. Enjoy. Hi, I'm Alex Goldman. This is Hyperfixed. On this show, listeners write in with their problems, big and small, and I solve them. Or, I mean, at least I try to. And if I don't, at least I have a good reason why I can't.
以同样的方式购买酸奶油或碎马苏里拉奶酪了。尽情享受吧。嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼。这里是《Hyperfixed》。在这个节目中，听众会写信讲述他们大大小小的烦恼，而我来解决它们。或者说，至少我试着去解决。如果我没能解决，至少我能给出一个合理的解释。
This week, Dylan's supermarket cold case. ["Dreams of a New World"] As a person who is close to the grocery store, do you find yourself going like? Oh, every day. Really? You're there every day? Every day I pop over there, milk, do you find yourself going like? Oh, every day. Really? You're there every day? Every day.
本周，迪伦的超市冷柜之谜。[《新世界的梦想》] 作为常去杂货店的人，你有没有发现自己会这样？哦，每天都去。真的吗？你每天都去？我每天都顺便去一趟，买牛奶，你有没有发现自己会这样？哦，每天都去。真的吗？你每天都去？每天都去。
I pop over there, milk, you know, to this morning, I need milk. Boom. This is Dylan. He lives across the street from a Safeway. And as you heard, he goes there every day. What are you often getting at the store? Man, definitely milk and cereal, bagels, all the breakfast food to eat every meal of the day.
我顺便过去，买牛奶，你知道的，今天早上，我需要牛奶。砰。这是迪伦。他住在一家 Safeway 超市的街对面。正如你所听说的，他每天都去那里。你在店里经常买什么？天哪，绝对是牛奶和麦片、百吉饼，所有这些可以当一天中每一餐的早餐食物。
What kind of cereal do you rock with? Today it was Captain Crunch, but normally it's like bran flakes. And because Dylan is making so many visits to Safeway, he's constantly confronted by this thing. This thing that most people probably wouldn't even question. But Dylan says he's been thinking about it for a long time actually, and he just didn't have anyone to ask about it. Until I came along.
你平时喜欢吃哪种麦片？今天吃的是脆麦王（Captain Crunch），但通常是像麸质麦片之类的。正因为迪伦频繁光顾 Safeway，他不断地面对着这样一样东西。这东西大多数人可能甚至都不会去质疑。但迪伦说，实际上他已经思考了很久，只是找不到可以询问的人。直到我出现了。
So I can't quite remember what I sent you guys, but the gist of it is like, you go to the grocery store, and it's unlike every other place on earth, their fridges don't always have like doors, right? And you would think that from just like an energy perspective perspective you would put a door in front of your fridge to not lose all your energy you're putting into cooling it. Okay this is a great point it's one that I make to my kids every time I catch them leaving the refrigerator
所以我记不太清我发给你们的是什么了，但大意是这样的：你去杂货店，它和地球上其他任何地方都不一样，他们的冰箱不总是没有门吗，对吧？你会觉得，单从节能的角度来看，你应该在冰箱前面装扇门，这样就不会白白浪费你用来冷却它所有的能量。好吧，这是一个很好的观点，这也是每次我抓到孩子们把冰箱
door open at home I'm like what are you doing you raised in a barn you're letting all the cold air out but for some reason when I'm in a grocery store and I see row after row of open refrigeration units letting all the cold air out. But for some reason, when I'm in a grocery store and I see row after row of open refrigeration units letting all the cold air out, it doesn't even register to me as a problem. Additionally, like the store has like a heating system, right, so it's like cooling the fridge air, but then it's heating the store air
门敞开时对他们说的话。我说：“你们在干什么？在谷仓里长大的吗？你们把冷气全放跑了！”但不知为什么，当我在杂货店里看到一排又一排敞开的冷藏柜把冷气全都释放出来时，不知为什么，当我看到杂货店里一排又一排的敞开式冷藏柜把冷气白白散发出去时，我甚至不觉得这是一个问题。此外，店里还有供暖系统，对吧，所以它一方面在冷却冰箱里的空气，但接着又在加热店里的空气
and it seems like a big waste. And waste is not just some casual concern for Dylan. He co-leads a climate group in Portland, and in his free time, he lobbies Congress about environmental issues. So definitely a big concern of mine is just like the climate environment. I don't always know the specific science behind like, you know, like why does a store have this refrigeration unit that does not seem very effective. So that is why Dylan came to us. First to figure out whether this whole open refrigeration system is really as wasteful
这看起来像是巨大的浪费。对迪伦来说，浪费不仅仅是一种随意的担忧。他在波特兰共同领导一个气候组织，在空闲时间，他会就环境问题向国会进行游说。所以，我绝对非常关心的一点就是气候和环境。我并不总是知道一些具体的科学原理，比如，你知道的，为什么商店里会有这样一个看起来不是很高效的冷藏柜。这就是迪伦来找我们的原因。首先是要弄清楚这个全敞开式的制冷系统是否真的像看上去那样浪费
as it seems. And second, if it is really that wasteful, why do grocery stores continue to be designed this way? Have you taken any steps to figure out why they are designed this way? Zero steps taken. I just reached it out to you. I feel like even though I've never spoken it aloud, it's been in my head. So it's nice to know that someone else is thinking about it.
那么浪费。其次，如果它真的那么浪费，为什么杂货店的设计还要继续保持这种样子？你有没有采取过任何步骤来弄清楚它们为什么被设计成这样？零步骤。我直接就联系了你们。我觉得尽管我从来没有大声说出来过，但这个问题一直留在我脑海里。所以很高兴知道还有别人也在想这件事。
And someone else is thinking about it to a degree that like you know I think about the dumb questions I have. I'm excited to try and answer this. After my call with Dylan, I drove to my local stop and shop for some research, which is what I call snacks, and as I walked around the store carrying a bag of Cool Ranch flavored research under my arm, I felt like I was really seeing the place for the first time. More than half of the refrigerated section was completely left open. There were no doors or plastic flaps covering even the most perishable food like yogurt and eggs. And later, when I went to Trader Joe's for more research, I saw that
而且有人居然也在思考这个问题，甚至达到了这样的程度——你知道的，我经常琢磨自己那些愚蠢的问题。我很兴奋能尝试解答这个问题。在和迪伦通话后，我开车去了当地的 Stop & Shop 超市做了一些“调研”，这就是我对零食的称呼，当我腋下夹着一袋酷 ranch（Cool Ranch）风味的“调研”零食走在店里时，我觉得自己真的是第一次真正看清这个地方。超过一半的冷藏区完全是敞开的。甚至连酸奶和鸡蛋这样最易腐烂的食品都没有门或塑料帘遮挡。后来，我去 Trader Joe's 做更多调研时，我看到
even the ice cream was being kept in open cooling units. Which, given what happens to the ice cream at my house when I accidentally leave the freezer open even a little bit, feels especially insane. None of this made sense to me. From a cost and energy standpoint, the whole design of the stores seemed so obviously inefficient. But the fact that they were all designed this way made me think there must be some other factor that made this make sense. Most of you probably know that I came from tech journalism and I learned the reason that a lot of software is designed the way it is, is to try and manipulate the end user to continue using it or use things a certain way. They call it dark patterns.
连冰淇淋都放在敞开式的冷藏柜里。鉴于我家里的冰淇淋只要我不小心把冰箱门稍微敞开一点就会发生的那种灾难，这感觉特别疯狂。这一切对我都毫无意义。从成本和能源的角度来看，整个商店的设计似乎显然是低效的。但它们都被设计成这样这一事实让我觉得，一定有其他因素让这一切变得合理。你们大多数人可能都知道我曾从事科技新闻工作，我了解到很多软件之所以那样设计，是为了试图操纵最终用户继续使用它或以某种方式使用它。他们称之为“暗黑模式”（Dark Patterns）。
As I was heading out of the store, I couldn't stop thinking about this idea that all these costly and inefficient refrigeration systems were trying to cajole people into a certain way of shopping. I just needed to find out what that certain way is. So I called a grocery store designer named Dan Phillips, and he was very much not the dark patterns mastermind I expected to find. I think everyone has their own creative outlet. Some do art, some paint, some play music.
当我正要离开商店时，脑子里一直挥之不去这样一个想法：所有这些成本高昂且效率低下的制冷系统，其实是在诱使人们以某种特定的方式购物。我只是想找出那究竟是怎样的一种方式。所以我打电话给一位名叫丹·菲利普斯的杂货店设计师，他完全不是我预想的那种深谙暗黑模式的幕后操盘手。我想每个人都有自己的创意发泄口。有人做艺术，有人画画，有人玩音乐。
And laying out a store is kind of an art, it's a thought process. Dan's family has been in the grocery store design business since 1972. He's super passionate about the work, and when I told him about my dark patterns theory of open refrigeration systems he was like okay first of all that's not what they're called. So if you go into that grocery store you'll go into the post department and they'll have that case in the wall that's refrigerated with a bunch of shelves on it and that is called an open-air multi-deck. If you didn't catch that, Dan says these refrigerated shelves are called open-air multi-decks. Open, because they're exposed to the elements, in this case the cool air of the supermarket environment.
而规划一家商店的布局其实是一种艺术，是一个思考过程。丹的家族从 1972 年就开始从事杂货店设计业务。他对这项工作充满热情，当我向他讲述我关于敞开式制冷系统的“暗黑模式”理论时，他说，好吧，首先，那不叫这个名字。如果你走进那家杂货店，你会走到果蔬区，墙上会有一个带有很多层架的冷藏柜，那东西被称为“开放式多层柜”（open-air multi-deck）。如果你没听清，丹说这些冷藏架被称为开放式多层柜。开放，是因为它们暴露在空气中，这里指超市环境的冷空气。
And multi-deck because the shelving is tiered to display rows and rows of produce and goods. The second thing he told me was that my whole dark patterns theory was way off, at least in his experience. Dan primarily works with mom-and-pop shops, not Safeway style supermarkets, but he says that when his clients are trying to decide what goes behind a refrigerator door and what doesn't, their primary consideration is customer experience. There are some products that work and some just don't. It works to put beer behind doors, you know, because you can sit there and you know what beer you're gonna get, right, and you can grab it out. Things like dairy and hot dogs also work great behind a door
多层，是因为货架是分层的，用来展示一排排的农产品和商品。他告诉我的第二件事是，我的整个“暗黑模式”理论完全离谱，至少以他的经验来看是这样的。丹主要与夫妻老婆店合作，而不是 Safeway 那样的大型超市，但他说，当他的客户试图决定什么东西该放在冰箱门后面、什么不该放时，他们首要考虑的是顾客体验。有些产品适合放后面，有些则不然。把啤酒放在门后面是行得通的，你知道的，因为你可以站在那儿，知道自己会买到什么啤酒，对吧，然后你把它拿出来。乳制品和热狗放在门后面也很棒
because you don't really need to examine them. Typically, you spot the label you like, open the door, pull it out, and you're done. For the produce and packaged meat, you know, those doors would be a hindrance done. For the produce and packaged meat, you know, those doors would be a hindrance there. You know, people will want to hold that open with their cart and look at all the different cuts of prime ribs that is there.
因为你真的不需要去仔细检查它们。通常，你一眼就能认出你喜欢的标签，打开门，把它拿出来，就搞定了。对于农产品和包装肉类，你知道的，装上门在那儿反而会成为一种阻碍。你知道的，人们会想要用购物车撑开门，去看看那里所有不同部位的上等肋排。
I never considered the idea that you'd have to stand there with the door open, but, like, now I'm thinking about the things that I get out of the freezer, which are chicken nuggets for my daughter, ice cream, all things that, like, I know I am fully aware of what it's going to taste like. There's not going to be any surprises. It's not going to have brown spots.
我以前从没想过你还得站在那儿开着门，但是，现在我想到了我从冷冻库里拿出的东西，比如给我女儿吃的鸡块、冰淇淋，所有这些东西，就像我完全清楚它是什么味道一样。不会有任何惊喜。不会有棕色的斑点。
It's not going to be a thing that I have to examine. Dan says that if you want to see good customer experience, design, and action, the best place to go is Costco. Going to Costco is one of my favorite experiences of all time. Because you can really see customer interaction and flow in a Costco store, just stand at the end of the frozen food aisle and kind of see how fast people are going in and out of that. And then go stand over by the meat department and just stand in the corner and watch how long people stand in the meat department and see how they interact and go through things and pick things up. And you'll see, okay, here's what doors do
不需要我去仔细检查。丹说，如果你想看清优秀的顾客体验和设计是如何发挥作用的，最好的去处就是 Costco。去 Costco 是我最喜欢的体验之一。因为你真的可以在 Costco 看到顾客的互动和动线，只要站在冷冻食品过道的尽头，看看人们进出那里的速度有多快。然后走到肉类专区旁边，站在角落里观察人们在肉类专区停留多久，看看他们是如何互动的、如何浏览商品以及挑选商品的。你会发现，好吧，这就是门的作用
and here's what open multi-decks do. And here's the products that are working and don't work. And honestly, it just comes down to making sure that you all are having an enjoyable experience so you come back. No sort of trickery. We just want you to come back and shop the independent store and not go down the street.
这就是开放式多层柜的作用。这就是那些行之有效和行不通的产品。老实说，归根结底就是为了确保你们所有人都有一个愉快的体验，这样你们才会再次光临。没有任何花招。我们只是想让你回来光顾这家独立商店，而不是去街那头。
Dan conceded that his work was driven more by the ideals of a good customer experience than raw dollars and cents data. And I conceded that, yeah, okay, I enjoy examining my meats and cheeses and putting them behind a door would be a bit of a pain in the ass. By the time I said goodbye to Dan, the idea of open multi-decks didn't seem quite as crazy anymore. But that was before I found out exactly how much energy these multidex are using. There's another Dan in this episode, and we are trying to figure out ways to differentiate
丹承认，他的工作更多是由良好顾客体验的理念驱动，而非冷冰冰的美元和美分数据。而我也承认，好吧，我确实喜欢仔细挑选我的肉类和奶酪，如果把它们关在门后面确实会挺麻烦的。在我向丹道别时，开放式多层柜的概念看起来似乎没那么疯狂了。但那是在我发现这些多层柜究竟消耗了多少能量之前。这集里还有另一个丹，我们在试图想办法区分
the two of you. I was wondering if you would be okay if we called you Science Dan. Well, I do prefer Daniel to Dan, but I'm happy for you to call me Science Daniel, or you call me whatever you like. Science Daniel. Perfect. This is Science Daniel, aka Daniel Whiteson. He's a professor of physics at UC Irvine and the host of a science explainer podcast called Daniel and Kelly's
你们俩。我想知道如果我们叫你“科学丹”，你介意吗？嗯，比起丹，我其实更喜欢丹尼尔（Daniel），但我很高兴你叫我科学丹尼尔，或者你想怎么叫我都行。科学丹尼尔。完美。这就是科学丹尼尔，也就是丹尼尔·怀特森（Daniel Whiteson）。他是加州大学尔湾分校的物理学教授，也是一档名为《丹尼尔和凯利的非凡宇宙》（Daniel and Kelly's Extraordinary Universe）的科学科普播客的主持人，该节目与制冷毫无关系。但当我找到一篇专门针对我们想要解答的问题的论文时——令人惊讶的是，关于这个特定问题有大量的科学文献——我觉得我需要一双经验丰富的科学之眼来过目一下。我确实读过很多科学论文，这绝对是你可以学会的一项技能。就像在读一本科幻小说。你会想：好吧，这段要来了。好吧，那段要来了。
Extraordinary Universe, which has nothing to do with refrigeration. But when I found a paper on the very question we'd set out to answer, and surprisingly there's a lot of scientific literature on this particular question, I felt like I needed a set of seasoned science eyes to give it a look. I do read a lot of science papers and it's definitely something you learn how to do. It's like reading a science fiction book. You're like, okay, here comes this bit. Okay, here comes that bit.
我需要略读一下，或者这一部分我需要非常仔细地阅读。所以这绝对是一项技能。就像一块肌肉。我发给科学丹尼尔的那篇论文发表于 2015 年。它的标题是《能源效率悖论：超市制冷系统投资决策案例研究》（The Energy Efficiency Paradox: A Case Study of Supermarket Refrigeration System Investment Decisions）。我只想知道：好吧，这到底是怎么回事？这些开放式多层柜在每个商店都有。它们真的像迪伦想象的那样浪费吗？
I need to skim that or this part I need to read really carefully. So it's definitely a skill. It's like a muscle. The paper I sent Science Daniel was from 2015. It's titled The Energy Efficiency Paradox, colon, a case study of supermarket refrigeration system investment decisions. And all I wanted to know was, okay, what gives? These open multi-decks are in every store. Can they really be as wasteful as Dylan imagines they are?
冰箱消耗了大量的能量。它占了超市总能耗成本的 50% 以上。你知道的，他们还要运营面包店、开灯，超市里有各种各样的事情在进行。但很大一部分消耗来自于冷藏食物和运转这些冷冻库。让这些东西保持寒冷需要消耗大量能量，特别是如果你没有给它们装门的话。所以，是的，这些设备消耗了大量的能量。但他也告诉我，开放式多层柜的设计与我家孩子们把
The fridges are using a huge amount of energy. It's more than 50% of the total cost of the energy of the supermarket. You know, they're like running bakeries, they got lights, they got all sorts of stuff going on in the supermarket. But a huge fraction comes from refrigerating that food and running those freezers. It costs a lot of energy to keep that stuff cold, especially if you don't have doors on it. So yeah, these things are expending a ton of energy. But he also told me the design of the open multi-deck is not the same as when my kids leave
冰箱门敞开时的情形并不一样。它的设计旨在比那种情况更高效。这些开门冰箱并不是完全愚蠢的。这不仅仅是你把家里的冰箱拿掉门，那样根本行不通。其中许多确实采用了专门的技术，比如把冷空气呈墙状喷射出来，利用层流来试图阻止暖空气渗入，但即便如此，所有这些花哨的技术等等，仅仅通过给这些冷柜装上门，你就可以节省至少 30% 的能源成本。我和一些
the fridge door open at home. It is designed to be more efficient than that. These open door fridges are not totally stupid. It's not just like you take your fridge at home and you remove the door, that wouldn't work very well. A lot of these do have specialized techniques where they like blast the cold air in a wall to use the laminar flow to try to prevent the warm air from leaking in, but still, even all the fancy techniques, etc. you could save at least 30% of the energy cost just by putting doors on these. And I spoke to some
这里的加州大学尔湾分校的气候专家交流过，他们估计这还是个保守数字。有了效率更高、密封更好的新型冰箱，这个数字至少可以达到 50% 甚至 70%。所以这是一个巨大的数字。我读过的一篇论文表明，仅仅通过给冰箱装上门，整个国家就能节省大约百分之一或百分之二的全国能源成本。我怎么强调都不为过。科学丹尼尔告诉我们，如果杂货店从开放式多层柜改用冰箱门，在整个杂货行业这些冰箱的使用寿命期间，他们可以省下大笔资金，高达数十亿美元。
climate experts here at UC Irvine and they estimated that that was a low figure. That with new refrigerators that are much more efficient and well-sealing doors, that number could be at least 50 or maybe even 70 percent. So it's huge. I read one paper that suggested that the whole country would save like one or two percent of our energy costs for the whole country. I can't stress that enough just by putting doors on the fridges. Science Daniel told us that if grocery stores made the switch from open air multi-decks to fridge doors, they could save big money in the billions of dollars over the lifetime
现在我可不是搞数学或科学的人，但我的理解是，十亿是个相当大的数字，很多个十亿加在一起就是一个非常大的数字。而许多个十亿加在一起，比那个还要大得多。而且不仅仅是因为维护开放式多层柜需要花费大量金钱。正如科学丹尼尔所解释的：为了能随手拿到酸奶冰棒而不必隔着一扇门，我们付出了巨大的金钱代价，并且污染了环境。这是一件大事。不过，细节也很重要。比如我们在这里讨论的能源使用及其对气候的影响，取决于这些能量的来源。
of these fridges across the entire grocery industry. Now I am not a math or science guy, but my understanding is that a billion is a pretty big number, and many billions together is a pretty big number. And many billions together is a much bigger number than that. And it's not just that it costs a lot of money to maintain open air multi-decks. As Science Daniel explains, The fact that you want to be able to reach you for your yogurt pops without going through a door is costing us a lot of money and polluting the environment. It's a big deal. Now the details are important though. Like what we're talking about here is energy use and the impact on the climate depends on where
因此，如果你的超市例如完全由风力发电供电，那么使用更多这样的能量对环境来说就不会产生任何成本。但如果你燃烧的是煤炭、天然气或其他什么——这仍然占了我们在美国能源的 60% 左右——那么，是的，你消耗的电力越多，他们燃烧的煤炭就越多，你的酸奶冰棒正在让整个地球变暖。哦，还有一件事我们甚至都没有考虑到。
that energy comes from. So if your supermarket was, for example, completely powered by windmills, then it wouldn't cost anything for the environment to use more of that energy. But if you are burning coal or natural gas or whatever, which is still like 60% of our energy here in the US, then yeah, the more power you draw, the more coal they burn and your yogurt pops are warming the whole planet. Oh, and there's one more thing that we didn't even consider.
科学丹尼尔刚才描述的那种聪明的、能让开放式多层柜比我家冰箱更高效运行的设计，是因为它们使用了制冷剂。而制冷剂对环境非常有害。在很多情况下比二氧化碳还要糟糕。而且即使是在最好的制冷设备上，这些制冷剂也会泄漏。这些制冷剂本身是非常非常糟糕的温室气体。二氧化碳是一种糟糕的温室气体，尽管它只占地球大气的一小部分。但还有其他气体，比如甲烷或更复杂的有机分子，它们甚至更糟糕，少量就能使
That clever design that Science Daniel was describing earlier that allows open multi-decks to run more efficiently than my home's fridge, that's because they use refrigerants. And refrigerants are very bad for the environment. Worse than CO2 in a lot of cases. And even on the best refrigeration unit, those refrigerants leak. These refrigerants themselves are really, really bad greenhouse gases. CO2 is a bad greenhouse gas, even though it's a tiny fraction of the Earth's atmosphere. But there are other gases like methane or more complex organic molecules that are even worse, that smaller amounts of can heat up
地球变暖更多。我读过加拿大广播公司（CBC）的一项研究，称其环境影响相当于燃烧数十亿乃至数千亿磅煤炭的排放量，基本上相当于全天候多运行了 150 座燃煤发电厂。好吧，很明显，迪伦不仅是正确的，而且他的觉悟比他自己意识到的还要深。超市现有的制冷系统确实对环境造成了影响。
the planet much more. And I read a study from the CBC that said that the environmental impact was equivalent to the emissions of burning billions and billions of pounds of coal, like basically running an extra 150 coal power plants full-time. Okay, so it's clear that Dylan was right in more ways than he was even aware of. The current refrigerator system at grocery stores has real environmental impacts.
那么，既然换装能为他们省钱并对环境更好，为什么杂货店不做出改变呢？广告之后，我将把这个问题直接带给消息源。我们欢迎收听由亚历克斯·戈德曼主持的《Hyperfixed》更多内容。所以在刚才的节目中，我发现这些开放式多层柜系统可以有多么浪费。这又把我带回了我们最初的问题。为什么那么多杂货店还在使用它们？
So why aren't grocery stores making the switch if it could save them money and be better for the environment? After the break, I take that question directly to the source. We're back with more from Alex Goldman and Hyperfixed. So before the break, I found out just how wasteful these open multi-deck systems can be. Which brought me back to the question we started with. Why do so many grocery stores use them?
我曾有一种理论，认为背后一定有什么不可告人的动机，某种让这一切变得合理的暗黑模式。而唯一能给出确切答案的人，就是迪伦家附近那家 Safeway 的老板，阿尔伯特森先生和夫人。（你知道的，因为 Safeway 是被 Albertsons 收购的。）总之，我不知道这个笑话好不好笑。
I had a theory that there had to be some ulterior motive, some dark pattern that would make this make sense. And the only people who could say for sure were the owners of Dylan's neighborhood Safeway, Mr. And Mrs. Albertson. You know, because of how Safeway is owned by Albertson's. Anyway, I don't know if that joke lands or not.
Albertsons 没有列出任何部门主管的联系方式。所以我决定给 Albertsons 的总公司打电话。正在拨打爱达荷州博伊西市的 Albertsons 公司电话。请从以下菜单选项中选择。对于现有或潜在供应商，按 5。哇，直接挂我电话。即使我回拨了，也联系不到任何人。甚至连语音信箱都没有。所以我们试着给他们的公司总部打电话。如果您是关于杂货配送或自提的咨询，请按 8。
Albertson's doesn't list contact information for any of their department heads. So I decided to call Albertson doesn't list contact information for any of their department heads, so I decided to call Albertsons main office. Calling Albertsons companies in Boise, Idaho. Please choose from the following menu options. For current or prospective suppliers, press 5. Whoa, just hung up on me. Even after I called back, I couldn't get anybody. There's not even a voice mailbox. So we tried calling our corporate office. If you are calling about your grocery delivery or pickup, please press 8.
他们把我转接给了他们的营销负责人。我不是他们的人，但我当然可以请我们相关部门给你回电来处理你的问题。她正在休假。于是我们联系了 Kroger、Costco、Whole Foods。感谢致电 Kroger 媒体关系部。请留言。顺便问一下，你知道美国所有主要杂货店背后其实只有大约五个品牌在控制吗？
They directed me to their head of marketing. I'm not for them, but I can certainly ask one of our relevant departments to give you a call back as it goes to your issue. She was on vacation. So we reached out to Kroger, Costco, Whole Foods. Thank you for calling Kroger's Media Relations Department. Please leave a e-mail message. By the way, did you know there's only like five brands controlling all the major grocery stores in the United States?
这是真的。同样真实的是，这些品牌中没有一个给我回电。最后，我写了一封电子邮件，解释了我所了解到的一切，并把它发给了大型杂货企业。但在截稿前，我还没有收到回复。所以，虽然我回答了迪伦的一个问题——我确切知道了这些开放式多层柜有多浪费——但我仍然不知道为什么他们还要继续使用它们。而且各大超市也无济于事。但时间在流逝。如果我无法直接向源头求证，我想到的第二好的办法
It's true. Also true is that none of those brands got back to me. Finally, I wrote an email explaining everything I'd learned and sent it to big grocery. But as of publication time, I have not heard back. So, while I'd answered one of Dylan's questions, I knew exactly how wasteful these open multidex were, I still didn't know why they continued using them. And the supermarkets were not helping. But the clock was ticking. And if I couldn't take this question straight to the source, I thought the next best thing
就是帕科·昂德希尔（Paco Underhill），《为什么我们买买买：购物科学》（Why We Buy: The Science of Shopping）一书的作者。当你走在一家商店里时，不是作为顾问，而是作为一个普通顾客，这种感觉是不是就像《黑客帝国》的结尾，当尼奥看到所有的绿色代码时那样？我脑补的画面是你能够看到像那样的地方每一个产品陈列决策背后的代码。嗯，我想其中很有趣的一部分在于，当地的杂货店经理
was Paco Underhill, the author of the book, Why We Buy, the science of shopping. When you're like walking through a store, not as a consultant, but just as a customer, is it like the end of the matrix when Neo sees all the green text? I'm imagining you being able to see the code behind every product placement decision in a place like that. Well, I think part of what is very interesting is that the local grocery store manager
已经厌倦了我给他提建议。哈哈哈哈！帕科经营着一家名为 Envirocell 的咨询公司，财富 100 强企业中近一半都是他的客户。他们之所以能够积累如此声名显赫的客户群，是因为他们拥有一种不可思议的能力：走进一个空间——无论是银行、零售空间还是餐馆——几乎能立即找出其效率低下的地方。让我们如此受欢迎的部分原因在于，我们可以提出非常直接的建议。这里有 10 件你明天就可以做的事，而且你能立刻看到有什么不同。
is tired of me giving him advice. Ha ha ha ha ha! Paco runs a consulting firm called Envirocell that counts nearly half of all Fortune 100 companies as its clients. And the reason they've been able to amass such a prestigious portfolio is because they have this uncanny ability to go into a space, be it a bank or a retail space or a restaurant, and almost immediately identify its inefficiencies. Part of what made us very popular is that we could come back with very immediate suggestions. Here are 10 things that you could do tomorrow and you can immediately see what the difference is.
他们之所以在这方面如此擅长，是因为一旦他们进入一个空间，就会收集大量数据。他们使用各种工具，从摄像头、访谈到眼动追踪眼镜，这些眼镜可以记录当你在某个环境中四处走动时，你的眼睛对不同刺激的反应方式。他们甚至有所谓的“追踪者”
The reason they're so good at this is because once they go into a space, they collect tons of data. They use everything from cameras and interviews to eye tracking glasses that record the ways your eyes react to different stimuli as you walk around a certain environment. They even have what they call trackers,
也就是那些在店里四处潜行、尽量不引人注目地观察人们购物的人。一旦收集到所有这些数据，他们就会运用环境心理学（这也是帕科在研究生阶段所学的专业）的原理对其进行分析。所以我抱有希望，如果说有什么人知道为什么超市要使用
which are people who just skulk around the store trying not to be noticed as they watch people shop. And once they get all that data, they analyze it using the principles of environmental psychology, which is what Paco studied in grad school. So I was hopeful that if anyone knew the hidden reason behind why supermarkets were using
这些极其低效的制冷系统的隐藏原因，那一定就是帕科。他确实知道。只是它远没有我想象的那样性感诱人。嗯，你需要意识到的一部分是，杂货店的基本设计是在 20 世纪 30 年代完成的。所以杂货店被设计成这样，不是为了效率，也不是为了投资回报。很简单
these wildly inefficient refrigeration systems, it was Paco. And he did. It just wasn't nearly as sexy as I wanted it to be. Well, part of what you need to realize here is that the basic design of a grocery store was done in the 1930s. So the reason grocery stores are designed this way is not for efficiency and not for return on investment. It's simply
因为这就是它们近百年来一直被设计成的方式，我们现在已经习以为常了，没有人费心去更新它。商店的物理设计以及牛奶是距离前门最远的固定装置的选择，所有的冷柜往往都在边缘地带，因为那里更容易供电。我的意思是，20 世纪 30 年代——也就是 90 年代前——杂货行业做出了一堆不同的决定，放到今天来看并不完全合理。包括倾向于选择开放式多层柜而不是封闭式冰箱的决定，
because that's the way they've been designed for nearly 100 years and we are so used to it now, no one has bothered to update it. The physical design of the store and choices where the milk is the farthest fixture away from the front door, all of the chillers tend to be on the periphery because that's where easier to supply power. I mean, there are a bunch of different decisions that were made in the grocery industry in the 1930s, which is 90 years ago, which don't make complete sense today. Including this decision to favor open multi-decks over closed refrigerators,
这个决定是基于 20 世纪 30 年代非常典型的一个观念，即超市购物者主要是带着孩子的家庭主妇。如果你考虑到一个带着孩子、推着购物车的人，你知道的，他们只有一只手，如果有人必须手动打开再去手动拿取，这比他们只需伸手去拿要费力得多。所以这一切都是关于易用性，这会潜移默化地影响他们的行为，让他们可能会多买一些东西。没错。很有趣。这可能是我想到的唯一一个专门为女性量身定制的大型设计选择，而这样做的目的就是为了让她们花更多钱。
which was made based on the very 1930s idea that supermarket shoppers were primarily homemakers with kids. If you think about somebody who's got a kid with them is pushing a cart, you know, that they have one hand and if somebody asked to physically open and then physically pick, that's more effort than if they just have to pick. So it's all about ease of use, and that's going to suddenly influence the behavior to maybe pick up more stuff. That's correct. It's funny. This may be the only large-scale design choice that I can think of that was made specifically with women in mind and it was done to get them to spend more money.
帕科说，从上到下，美国的超市都早就该进行彻底改造了。如果我们从其他国家寻找灵感，我们会发现那些能带来各种节省（包括能源节省）的设计。我可以谈谈世界上其他地方的杂货店，他们不采用 90 度角，而是采用 45 度角。这意味着，虽然我失去了 20% 的货架空间，但从顾客的角度来看，所有东西都直观得多。
Paco said from top to bottom, the American supermarket is overdue for a makeover. And if we look at other countries for inspiration, we'll find designs that yield a whole host of different savings, including energy. I can talk about grocery in other parts of the world where rather than going with a 90 degree angle, they deal with a 45 degree angle. And what that means is that while I'm losing 20% of my shelf space, everything is much more visual from the standpoint of the customer.
他们看到的东西更多，与商品的互动也更多。哦，如果它是 45 度角，他们就能看到更多的过道。没错。正是如此。帕科还告诉我，在一些拉美国家，有些超市通过叉车来补货。所以，他们不是派人推着购物车把东西重新放回货架上，而是开着叉车出来，把整个货架抬起来，运回后室。有一个团队负责重新补货，然后叉车再把它运回卖场并放回
They see more things and are interacting with more things. Oh, if it's at a 45 degree angle, they can see more of the aisle. That's right. Correct. Paco also told me that in some Latin American countries, there are supermarkets that get their shelves restocked via forklift. So rather than sending somebody out to put things back on the shelf from a cart, they come out with a forklift truck, they pick up the shelf, they take it back to the back room. There's a team that restocks it, and then the forklift truck takes it back out on the floor and puts it back
原来的位置。在劳动力成本方面，这样节省的费用大约是 20%。美国有人在做类似的事情吗？还没有，但我估计快了。我对帕科以及他将心理学与商业联系起来以产生现实世界成果的方式印象深刻。我问他：“嘿，像我这样初露头角的播客大亨，你有什么建议吗？”而帕科的回答是：“没有，你干得很好。”然后他就从我们的 Zoom 会议中退出了，就像他出现时一样快。此时，我觉得是时候和迪伦聊聊了。所以我很好奇你对这一切有什么感觉。
in its place. And the cost savings there in terms of labor is about 20%. Is anybody here in the US doing anything like that? Not yet, but maybe soon. I was so impressed by Paco and the way he connected psychology with business to produce real world results. I asked him like, hey, do you have any advice for a budding podcast tycoon like me? And Paco was like, nope, you're doing great. And then he signed out of our zoom just as quickly as he'd appeared. And at this point, I thought it was time to catch up with Dylan. So I'm curious how you feel about all this.
绝对感觉不太好。这很难怪迪伦。本质上，我们所做的是证实了他心中的恐惧，却连那些能够为此做点什么的人都无法联系到。制作这个节目的过程中我很快就明白了一点：解决问题的行为本身往往会制造出新的问题。一个月前，我还没有注意到杂货店的冰箱根本没有门。而现在，迪伦不仅发现自己最糟糕的恐惧成了现实，我还觉得自己每周有两到三次在同谋污染这个世界。
Definitely not good. It was hard to blame Dylan. Essentially what we'd done was manage to confirm a fear he had while being unable to even talk to the people who could do anything about it. I'm learning very quickly making this show that the act of solving problems can create problems of its own a Month ago, I didn't notice that grocery store fridges didn't have doors on them at all And now not only has Dylan found his worst fears are true. I feel complicit in polluting the world like two to three times a week
但你知道，我也喜欢牛奶、黄瓜和草莓，所以我不能不用杂货店的冷藏柜。我想，如果非要说有什么一线希望的话，至少我帮迪伦证明他是对的。这确实是值得担忧的事情。我想这种认知就像，你知道的，我并没有疯，觉得“哇，这看起来真的很浪费。”它是真的。听起来真的很浪费。现在会有一个播客，数以千计的人会听到它，他们会想：“那个迪伦，他太对了。”
But you know, I also like milk and cucumbers and strawberries, so I can't just not use grocery store coolers. I suppose if there's any silver lining at all, at least I helped prove Dylan was right. That this is something to be concerned about. I guess the knowledge, like, you know, I'm not insane in thinking that like, wow, this seems really wasteful. It is. It is really wasteful, it sounds like. And now there's gonna be a podcast that many thousands of people will listen to, and they'll be like, that Dylan, he is so right.
沉冤得雪。现在我的未婚妻没法质疑了。哦，她之前质疑过吗？没有，但我觉得她才不管呢，她会觉得：“随便吧。”这世界上还有别的事要操心呢。我是说，确实有，但如果你能在这个世界上找到任何一点安慰奖的话，那就是能够对你的另一半说：
Vindicated. Now my fiance can't question it. Oh, was she questioning it? No, but I don't think she was, she was like, whatever. There's other things to worry about in this world. I mean, sure there are, but you can go back to, if there's any consolation prize in this world, it is being able to tell your significant other,
我是对的。千真万确。如果算上迪伦、我、阿莫尔（Amor）和埃玛（Emma），这就成了四个经常逛杂货店的人，现在他们敏锐地意识到了我们正在摧毁地球的这个重大方式。这还不足以掀起一场社会变革的浪潮，但如果你听到这些，并且你也觉得买鹰嘴豆泥之类的东西让你感觉像吃了苍蝇一样糟糕，
I was right. This is true. If you count Dylan, me, Amor, and Emma, that makes four of us regular grocery shoppers that are now keenly aware of this one big way we're destroying the planet. That's not exactly enough to start a groundswell of social change, but if you heard this and you too are feeling like crap about buying hummus or whatever,
我会把那五家大型杂货企业集团的联系方式放在shownotes里。《Hyperfixed》由埃玛·科特兰（Emma Cortland）、萨里·萨法尔·苏内克（Sari Safar Sukenek）和阿莫尔·雅各布（Amor Yates）制作。由埃玛·科特兰和阿莫尔·雅各布剪辑。由我——亚历克斯·戈德曼主持。音乐由神秘的“破缸者”（Breakmaster Cylinder）和我共同创作。由托尼·威廉姆斯（Tony Williams）担任音频工程。本集由索娜·阿瓦基安（Sona Avakian）进行事实核查。那个带有模拟喇叭、发出“哔哔哔”声音的桥段，我完全是从杰米·洛夫图斯（Jamie Loftus）那里抄来的。
I'll put the contact info for the five big grocery conglomerates in the show notes. Hyper Fixed was produced by Emma Cortland, Sari Safar Sukenek, and Amor Yates. It was edited by Emma Cortland and Amor Yates. It was hosted by me, Alex Goldman. The music is by the mysterious Breakmaster Cylinder and me. It was engineered by Tony Williams. The episode was fact-checked by Sona Avakian. The bit with the ham horn where it was like pew pew pew. I ripped that off whole cloth from Jamie Loftus.
请去听听她的播客《第16分钟》（16th Minute）。真的非常棒。从现在开始，我们将每两周发布一集新节目，并在非更新周发布精选加更节目。你可以在 hyperfixpod.com/join 获取加更节目、加入我们的 Discord 以及了解更多内容。此外，如果没有需要解决的问题，节目就无法存在，所以请前往 hyperfixpod.com 并提交你的烦恼。《Hyperfixed》是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的自豪成员，这是一个由独立创作者拥有、听众支持的播客网络。
Please listen to her podcast, 16th Minute. It's seriously so good. From this point forward, we are going to have a new episode every other week and bonus episodes in the off weeks. You can get bonus episodes, join our Discord and much more at hyperfixpod.com slash join. Also, the show can't exist without problems to solve, so head on over to hyperfixpod.com slash join. Also, the show can't exist without problems to solve, so head on over to hyperfixpod.com and submit your problems. Hyperfix is a proud member of Radiotopia from PRX, a network of independent creator-owned listener-supported podcasts.
在 radiotopia.fm 发现有远见的音频。非常感谢收听。我马上就要开始了。请在各大播客平台订阅《Hyperfixed》。每两周更新一集新节目，非更新周发布加更节目。你可以在 hyperfixpod.com 了解更多关于节目的信息并注册成为高级会员。shownotes 里会有链接。我也强烈建议你收听亚历克斯·戈德曼此前在 99PI 的两次亮相。他的故事《Heyoon》是他制作的有史以来第一个叙事音频纪录片。
Discover audio with vision at radiotopia.fm. Thanks so much for listening. I'm going to go ahead and get started. Subscribe to Hyperfixed wherever you listen to podcasts. New episodes every other week and bonus episodes on the off weeks. You can learn more about the show and sign up to be a premium member at hyperfixedpod.com. We'll have a link in the show notes. I also highly recommend that you listen to Alex Goldman's two previous appearances on 99PI. His story Heyoon was his first narrative audio documentary, like ever. And it continues to be an all-time favorite episode, so check that
它一直是大家最喜欢的经典单集之一，所以去听听看吧。还有去看罗曼·马斯的马自达病毒那一集。能和《Reply All》有那样的跨界合作真是太有趣了。shownotes 里也会有这些节目的链接。这是我们的节日休息周，但我们下周就会携新节目回归，以更多迷你故事开启新的一年。到时见。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
out. And also check out the Roman Mars Mazda virus episode. It was so much fun to have that crossover with Reply Hall. We'll have links to those in the show notes too. This was our holiday off week, but we will be back with a new episode next week, kicking off the new year with more mini stories. See you then. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
另外，也可以听听罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）的马自达病毒那一期。很高兴能与《Reply All》进行这次联动。我们也会在节目文稿中附上这些链接。这是我们的假期休息周，不过我们下周将带着新的一期节目回归，以更多微型故事开启新的一年。到时见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。